Speaker 1: Let's go to Adam from North Carolina.
Adam, please, please welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Thank you for having
me. David, last time I called in
was about bumper stickers a long time ago.
Speaker 1: Please. Great to have you here.
Speaker 4: I have to say, Ronda Santos, I'm not a
fan of him yet, but he's going to steamroll Trump.
And if it's Biden, he's going to steamroll Biden.
Speaker 1: You think? What? What what
evidence do you have to suggest that?
Speaker 4: Well, I really I wasn't so much into
Ron. I don't like him. But then I started looking
into him and I was like, this guy went to Harvard,
he went to Yale, he went to Naval Justice School.
He's got a really strong background that's going
to be like on paper, he looks good. Well, one.
Speaker 1: Of the funny things about that is
sometimes going to Harvard is good if you're
a Republican and sometimes it's proof that
you're so some kind of woke leftist. That's
very funny. The Harvard thing, whether they
like people who went to Harvard or didn't, it kind
of depends whether they're left or right wing. But
you're getting to something that I've said before,
which is I think Ron DeSantis pretends to be much
dumber than he actually is.
Speaker 3: Yes.
Speaker 4: I truly believe he
he's the 4D chess player. Trump,
the Trump's the guy who pretends to play for DHS.
Speaker 1: The part I do hesitate on with
DeSantis is I don't he's so uncharismatic and
I don't know that you can you know, he can dumb
himself down to appeal to Florida voters from
his Harvard education. But it's hard to create
charisma where there is none. And on a national
campaign, I just don't know what that would
be like. We're going to have to wait and see.
Speaker 4: I agree. It's going to be interesting
and I'm sure everything is going to be rubbing
up here soon. Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you so much
for calling in. Thanks to everyone who
called in. We're going to take a break
and we will take calls again in 2022.
2023 is not here yet. And the phone calls
will continue. Quick break. Be right back